approving the vaccine or recommending
this vaccine for approval
and we even heard today during the open
public hearing session
several medical professionals who talked
about approving
i think that the distinction between an
eua
product which is still an
investigational product
and the full approval of a full a
product under full approval with a blf
is a distinction we need to maintain and
i think we're
we're losing that simply by looking at
this as an
age-related uh anyone over the
18 years of age and and older uh it
doesn't strike me as really addressing
the emergency
which is which is severe and serious
life-threatening cova disease in
specific populations so i have a lot of
problems
because this could be interpreted as us
actually recommending
full approval of the vaccine and in the
minds of the general public that may
happen and may preclude
adequate um not only adequate
uh evaluation of this vaccine but
other future uh and ongoing uh
uh covid vaccines uh in development
thank you
i uh appreciate your concern
uh i wonder if dr gruber could address
uh amending the because the in
the emergency use authorization
but the question doesn't really state
that
um so
when we publish the agenda for this
verbage
committee meeting the topic is
the committee will meet an open session
to discuss
emergency use authorization of the
covet 19 vaccine for the prevention of
covet 19 in individuals 18 years of age
and older
so that is the topic
of today's verb discussion it is to
discuss
emergency use authorization that's
that's what the agenda says
we phrased this question the way we
phrased it because
as was stated under an a vaccine
authorized under an eoa is
a product that has not been approved
it's it's a non-approved
product and under the eoa
in order for us to rent or issue an eoa
we have to make a determination
that the benefits of the product
outweigh its risk
do we just add marion what if we just
add the words eua under an eua
to this voting question would that be
possible
based on the totality of scientific
evidence available
do the benefits of the madonna covet
outfit
its risk um for your use
under an eua in individuals
for use under an eoa in individuals 18
years of age and older
um we can you have to take those to your
lawyers or
can you make a discrimination we can do
this
we can say for use and then eoa
individuals 18 years of age and older
if the committee needs that
clarification
then i think we can safely do so
dramatically yes
yes please dr hilton the question is
very clear
do we think that this vaccine's benefits
outweigh the risk
if we think that then the
the fda will make a decision as to
whether or not to issue an eua
that's not what we're voting on we're
voting on whether the benefit to this
vaccine
outweighs the risk and then it's up to
the fda
to
make a decision as to whether or not
they're going to issue the uua so i
think the question should be left
exactly as it is
i completely support dr hildreth
i have a little trouble with it the way
it's written also
because um it's going to be very hard to
study other vaccines experimental
vaccines
when a person looks at uh
at this sentence and what i would
suggest
is that we write through uh
uh two months of follow-up
or put some qualification in there that
uh defines the length of time that it's
it's it's been evaluated because this is
a blanket statement
that everybody over 18 years of age you
get it no
this is this is
um this is the question that that is
phrased the way it's raised
because it's we want to know if on an
eoa where the
where the vaccine the the product is
still considered
a non-approved product but
needs to could be given during a public
health emergency
if the benefits of this product outweigh
the risk
it does not imply that it under an eoa
then of course
if we determine that the benefits
outweigh the risk
under the authorization and then eoa
authorization
it can be given then in to individuals
18 years of age
and older but that does not equal that
the product is approved
but a lot of people won't understand
that things
could you say at least this experimental
vaccine
i think once we start qualifying
in terms of the duration or anything
like that
it's going to be so confusing because
the duration will get longer as we go
arnold let me offer an alternative
marion
what about the people at risk
let me just say that we have a question
now
we are advisory to fda
they have put in a question that they
feel comfortable with
am i correct marian and that is what we
are voting on
if the vote is not in favor then we can
discuss this further marine how should
we perceive
i would like to proceed with keeping the
voting question as currently phrased
okay
dr hildreth yes are we going to go back
and retrospectively change
the question we voted on for fiverr
well that's another issue i was thinking
of this is exactly how would i explain
that we have a different question
yeah how would we explain that
yes i i get it i get that doctor
that's the question that's not related
to the phrasing but a very important one
to the question
yes please uh dr dr fuller and then
we'll try to go by
in order it's it's it's a lot easier to
manage
thank you dr gruber i hope this does
i definitely hope this does not happen
um but what if there is some adverse
event that appears
that is very broad that this is not
not that the if we think the benefits
outweigh the risk but
it turns out the risks are so high how
does this eua
get
withdrawn what would be the conditions
to say that we can no longer do this
so um dr fink had
elaborated on in his um introductory
remarks
and eoa and he did say this last week
and i believe he said it today too
can be revoked and and there can be
several reasons
so one it could certainly be if we
see that the risks outweigh the benefits
of that product
then we can revoke the eoa so that is
and but that's
right now we're voting on the data or we
we're looking at benefit and risk based
on the data
available to us um and as we had
presented them today
and we of course as was stated we will
have continued
follow-up active safety follow-up of the
recipients
um of this vaccine under an eoa and if
we
determine that the risks are no longer
well acceptable and that the risks
outweigh the benefits
then they can revoke the eoa dr fuller
and fda would do that
and the fda would do that okay thank you
thank you for the clarification
yeah dr robert let's just go
bob by recognizing the individuals i
recognize
thank you so so um yeah i disagree with
dr meisner
i think the question that's being asked
us is do we have enough evidence
in hand to say that the benefits of this
vaccine outweigh what at the moment are
as far as severe safety issues are
theoretical risks
i think the answer
that question is is clearly yes i mean
the question is never
when do you know everything it's when do
you know enough you know we have
trials of 44 000 and 30 000 that's as
big as any general pediatric
vaccine trial the difference is length
of follow-up so we don't know whether or
not it's going to be
effective six months from now or a year
now but there are systems in place to
know that
we don't know whether or not it's going
to have a rare serious side effect which
is true of any medical product
but there are systems in place to know
that and frankly given given what we
know so far about
the the height of the immune response
about what we have with you know with t
helper cell and cytotoxicity
so far we can feel pretty comfortable
that this vaccine is going to
have a benefit that lasts for more than
the three months or so that we studied
it
i think it's a pretty easy answer you
can't qualify things as being
experimental
because you could always say that about
any medical product i mean
when the hpv vaccine came out we could
say well we think that
you know that it's okay first for seven
years because that's all we have data
for it so i think the answer to this
question at least as far as i'm
concerned
i completely agree with dr gams is
clearly yes
thank you dr cohen and we're going to be
discussing this until five o'clock
eastern
and at that time we're going to put it
to the vote because there's
also another chance to explain your vote
afterwards
um
go ahead i would just ditto to um what
dr office
just said
i completely agree that the question is
the right question um
and uh the data clearly
uh suggests the the data uh
clearly showed that the benefits
outweigh the risk
okay dr perkins
thanks um i completely agree with dr
rafat and dr ganz i think
the the preponderance of data is totally
in support of
um moving us forward i don't see any
value in changing
the terminology of this particular
voting question i also think
this idea that this
that the eua process is going to change
future
um vaccine trials etc is a little bit
feels a little bit
strange to me we're talking about a
pandemic which is
you know not very common where we really
need to move this forward and there's
really an effort to get this done
quickly i
i don't see as much of a risk in the
long term
that this process is going to
be used on a regular basis for other
vaccine trials so i think we need to
focus on what's at hand and focus on the
question here and i think there's
there's no doubt in my mind that the
data is is it looks like the
the benefits outweigh the risk from what
i've seen
mr tubman yes i'm
um
my camera's not coming on but can you
hear me
yeah we can hear you so i'm
i'm fine with the question as is because
it says based on the totality of
scientific scientific evidence available
meaning that's what we have today um and
based upon that
on balance strong data particularly on
severity
and severe disease um i think the
balance supports it
um i did have a concern though with uh
i'm glad there's discussion about
whether to change the question or not
because i was troubled
by the fact that the fda was weighing in
again
i want the question for us changing the
question
and basically we've been told this is an
independent committee
and we want to be transparent if the
committee feels that a question
should be changed committee should
change it there doesn't seem to be
a willingness to the committee's
decision and the answer dr gruber gave
us well first
go to my question and then after that
if it doesn't pass would you do a
different question that in reality
doesn't work
because almost nobody's going to want to
vote no to this question as written
you deprive people the opportunity and
this happened
last time not to bring up the whole
story but with either there was strong
feelings about including 16 and 17 year
olds
and and because that was not presented
as a separate question which it should
have been
people were sort of forced to have to
make a choice but i think the committee
really should be independent and decide
for themselves whether the question is
acceptable or not in this case i think
it's fine
dr meisner
i didn't really
i didn't realize my hand was still up so
okay well
thank you no
i will let you have some burning thing
to say
no i want all i want to say arnold is
that i agree with
what everyone has said and i am in favor
of
yes on this question my only point is
i don't want people to interpret this
the same way they would
a licensed vaccine it's it is
as uh has been stated based on the
available evidence
but that's limited but if everyone else
is comfortable with this
i'm fully comfortable and
in reality cody whatever we say
the media is going to say interpret it
in whatever way they want so
yes uh
dr warrick
so the question is written seems to be
aligned with
how we think about eua and
based on the totality of scientific
evidence available i
strongly support that the benefits of
the vaccine outweigh its risk for use
in individuals 18 years ago
okay dr naden
question
the answer is yes to the question thank
you okay well
okay then you don't have to explain your
vote afterwards
all right
doctor chatterjee and then finally dr
rubin and then we will uh
uh floats the question
thank you dr montreal um i just wanted
to follow up on on several of the
previous committee members that
commented on this
and i understand the difficulty that
some people are having
uh with with the wording perhaps you
know as scientists we tend to be
very precise in in what we say and we
want it to be as
as to the point as possible but i think
what is not mentioned in the question
and of course what we are all talking
about is that
we're making this decision during a
pandemic and so
it is this
really unique circumstance that is
forcing us in some ways
to um word the question in this way and
and to answer the question in this way
so i would say i'm comfortable with the
way the question is written
and willing to vote on it thank you
and finally dr reuben
thank you i um i
you can hear me um yes we can
and see you thank you
thanks um i'm glad to be recognized
just want to remember why we're here um
we're here to provide uh for two reasons
that i can think of to provide the fda
advice and to see if i
that they want um so we get so hung up
on the question because they are
they make decisions we don't um and and
the second reason we're here is to
is to inspire
confidence in the public that we've
looked carefully at the data
um and i i think when we just when we
worry about
the details of the wording i'm not sure
that we're helping people understand
that
what i almost certainly will be a very
strong vote
in favor is just a strong vote in paper
thank you dr rubin it's a delight to
come to the
end when i don't see any hands raised
which was not the case last week
so now let's call the question so
we are going to be voting and then after
the vote
those who wish to explain the vote will
have a chance to do so by raising their
hands
thank you dr monto can everybody hear me
okay
yes we can okay
so our members and temporary voting
members
as seen on the next slide
excluding the industry representative
will be voting in today's meeting
and in regards to the voting process
dr manta will read the question for the
record and afterwards
all members and temporary members will
cast their vote by
selecting one of the voting options
these include yes no or abstain
you will have two minutes to cast your
vote after the question has been read
once all the votes have been placed we
will broadcast the results
and read the individual votes allowed
for the record
please note that once
if you cast your vote you can change
your vote within the two-minute time
frame however once the vote has closed
all votes will be considered final does
anybody have any questions related to
the voting process before we begin
okay i don't see any questions so dr
monto if you'd like to go ahead and read
the
question the question that we are voting
on
is
based on the totality of scientific
evidence available due to the benefits
of the moderna covet 19 vaccine
outweigh its risks for use
in individuals 18
years of age and older
thank you so members contemporary voting
members you have
two minutes to go ahead and cast your
vote
arnold this is mark sawyer i want to
point out that my vote says
pfizer by in tech not moderna right
this is this is the wrong vote
you are right i was busy
trying to find where the voting was
can we can we re yes we will be taking a
re-vote just one moment
can we just revo revoked last week's
vote
yeah we might get a different conclusion
so
got the right one up down yes i believe
the question has been updated
so we will restart the
timer and clear out the current results
so we can take another reboot
you
we have 30 seconds remaining
okay our two minutes is up so if we
could
go ahead and close the vote and
broadcast the results
and i will read the individual the
individual votes allowed for the record
so dr cohn we have a yes vote
dr sawyer voted yes dr rubin yes dr
carrillo
abstain dr pearlman yes dr schooley yes
dr gans yes dr lee yes
dr moore yes
dr chatterjee yes dr meisner yes
dr fuller yes dr hildreth yes
dr neaton yes
dr offit yes dr wharton yes
dr kim yes dr pergam yes
dr mckenna yes dr amanto yes mr talman
yes
and that concludes the vote
it looks like we have a favorable vote
so i will um
pass the floor back to dr monto thank
you everybody
thank you for putting in your votes
today thank you now
anybody who would like to explain their
vote
should raise their hands uh
mr taubman is first thank you
um i i voted yes because the balance is
strong
last time
can you hear me we can
um
balance is strong for approval so that's
the way i voted last time i
i did recommend that we not grant eua
broadly but rather limited limited to to
priority groups
to allow for further data to be
collected
and since there's limited supply anyway
and that would be to preserve
the data we would get going forward that
was
not accepted by folks but we were
assured
that when pfizer moved forward people
who were not
priority groups would be maintained in
the study
and that was really important to me
i'm very concerned about modernist
proposal
and it does sound like from the
discussion i know
fda did not want to vote on that i can
see why
but it seemed like there was strong
support for if they're going to
unwind they should do it on the basis of
when a group comes up in its
priority and not unlike everyone right
away which is what moderna has proposed
i think that would be really disservice
um
finally i did want to say thank you to
the fda folks though because
um they put a tremendous amount of work
into this i think dr meiser said this at
the beginning of the meeting
and there's a very long hours reviewing
the data understanding this
working with the sponsors um they've
been under tremendous pressure here
and even they've been under improper
political pressure even bullying and
threats
and i think they valiantly resisted that
and showed that science was going to
prevail here so a
big gratitude to the hard-working fda
folks
dr marx on down thank you thank you
uh mr tubman dr fuller you would like to
explain your vote
yes i would thank you um first of all i
want to thank the fda for the incredible
work they've
done and this committee is
so for the um transparency that went in
today's
um schedule and having more time
we're in an unparalleled crisis
um i did not think an eua was the way to
go but since the train has left the
station
i appreciate that moderna has given us a
very transparent and thorough study
that even from the beginning seemed to
be very well
organized with getting people with
underlying conditions
with monitoring activity throughout the
study with even including the serology
and nasal swabs which are not completely
analyzed at the moment but which have
great potential to look at important
aspects
and then lastly the care for the study
participants throughout
including a plan for monitoring adverse
effects
as well as what to do with people who
now may want to
move in from the placebo so i appreciate
the way that they've conducted a much
more transparent and clean study and
lastly i know that now that we have
that thing available that we still have
to use the preventions that are
available
such that we can uh keep each other safe
as we go through getting
do the type of protection uh however
long it lasts so i want to thank fda
and all of you for helping with this
discussion today
and that's why i said yes i didn't feel
that way last time
thank you thank you dr fuller dr
carrillo and then for the final word uh
dr hildreth
yeah thank you arnold um camera not
working again
uh i i abstain because of i'm very
uncomfortable with the language i think
in the
in the midst of a pandemic and with
limited vaccine supply
available a blanket statement for
individuals 18 years of older and older
is just too
broad i'm not convinced that for all of
those age groups the benefits do
actually outweigh the risks and i would
prefer to see it more
targeted towards people at high risk of
serious uh and life-threatening covet
disease and we have
that they have that information and we
and we understand
to a certain extent those high-risk
groups so it could be
it could be targeted lastly i would have
preferred to have seen
rather than an emergency use
authorization route an expanded access
program i think it would have
given us a lot more opportunities to
continue
to collect the data and my concern about
future vaccines was not on non-covered
vaccines but other coveted vaccine
candidates that are in various stages of
development
thank you dr
hildreth
uh thank you dr mancha
sorry about the train i just want to
make the point
what a remarkable scientific
achievement this is and say thanks to
all the scientists
present and past who contributed to this
to go from having a sequence of a virus
in january to having two vaccines
available in december it's a remarkable
achievement and i just
want to say that and congratulate all
those who invite
thank you thank you dr
childress you've echoed my feeling about
uh what a re remarkable
achievements has been a chia has been
reached here
uh having the sequence less than a year
ago
uh i just wanted to make one or two
comments before closing
our vote was even more overwhelming
tonight than last week i don't
think that anyone should interpret
the difference in the vote being one way
or another comparing the two vaccines
that we have considered
academics have a way of getting involved
in details
and what we have done for the last
eight or nine hours was to go over the
details
and some people took
the issues last week especially
those involving different age groups
the 16 and 17 year olds
to drive the decision
that they made which clearly
was made based on that
issue and not on the overwhelming
evidence
or risk being less
than benefit a clear benefit with these
vaccines
so i'd just like to close by thanking
the committee members thanking
fda for giving us an
agenda which allowed much more
open discussion which i think benefits
all of us
including trying to
advise fda on some of these very tough
issues that we are facing
and congratulations to us all for
achieving this emergency use
authorization
or a second vaccine which
along with other events will
eventually and sooner we hope break the
back of the pandemic
now i'd like to hand the floor over
to our dr etreya to formally close the
meeting
dr atreya you're dr dre your phone's
muted
i'm sorry uh thank you all uh dr
monto um we described
my sentiments and you all did a great
job and thank you for all your service
and
first we greatly greatly appreciate it
and then
so uh yeah i would formally close this
meeting
this meeting is adjourned now thank you
very much
have a good evening
thank you good good night to everybody
good night thank you
thank you dr thank you all and with that
we will officially adjourn
uh though